this is going to get right a heart of
whether you understand what absolute
value is okay and particularly if you're
able to use those definitions and
interpret okay how these definitions
lead to something practical
okay so what's tricky about this there's
really only one curveball in this
question is the fact that it's an
absolute value signs around the Y you're
like well I'm not used to it doesn't fit
what I'm used to seeing and so you don't
use the normal rules but actually this
will fit all the same rules you already
know okay so first I need let's have a
look at this part absolute value - okay
by definition I'm thinking of the moment
of definitions of three three by
definition of three as you they act is
equal to something at one time and
something else at another time right in
a particular domain so for instance
sometimes it's just equal to X where is
it equal to just X when X is positive
right yeah actually when is a better way
to choose okay obviously alternate if X
is negative then the absolute value of x
is equal to
all right now it exactly the same way
why the absolute value of y is going to
follow the same rules except it's not
gonna be about externa it's gonna be
about Wyatt right so this is going to be
equal to Y where Y is positive yes and
where Y is not positive where it's
negative it's gonna be before ok now
this seems a little bit confusing I
still did this off the face of it but
actually these four different
restrictions corresponds having we're
very familiar with actually accent okay
keep in mind right because one of them's
had X and one of them that about Y right
you combine them together so for
instance you have an x and a y then you
have the same X and the other one and
you get different combinations you get
four of them okay so for instance where
X is positive I'm looking at the right
hand side of the graph all right so I'm
over here huh and then where Y is
positive I'm looking at the top
so where are both of those true we have
a name for that we call it the first
quadrant right this is X is greater than
zero and Y is greater than zero up here
in this corner of the of the Cartesian
plane okay it exactly the same way over
here I still have X is positive but now
why is they right that makes sense and
then I can keep on going around so four
quadrants four different descriptions of
the inequality okay so I'll just fill it
out I've got the negative case over here
for X for one okay excellent
so now that I've identified what the
values of x are what the values of Y's
are now I can do which of these cases
I'm going to take okay so for instance
let's take the easiest one okay up here
in the first quadrant where I have both
of the positive cases yes so the
absolute value of x will just be x
and I hear the absolute value I would
just be wine okay so up in this region
over here I'm just going to be graphing
oh yes
that's what I'm going to be graphic okay
only up here though only up here soon as
I cross over or cross over this way I'm
equal to something else so let's go down
in this case X is still positive but now
why isn't it right so if X is positive
the absolute value of X is just X but
now because Y is negative the absolute
value of y is minus y so down in this
region over here
I'm X minus y see what I'm doing here
right I just go through case by case and
I can see I've got different equations
in different places right I just can't
complete the pattern over here X is
negative so I'm gonna get Y is positive
so that's that and then down here
they're both okay so now I can draw this
thing right let's take it one step at a
time we don't usually see it in this
form this is not this is not a general
form or slope-intercept form so I'm just
gonna reread it just a little bit right
so we know what that looks like I'm
going to draw that okay now that's what
1 minus X looks like 1 1 and you can see
it stops right in fact I'm never gonna
put the boundaries on there because it's
only equal to this in this part which is
the first quadrant and then I'm finished
there's no other place that my original
graph is equal to this particular line
okay now come down over here all right
what's this thing gonna look like
one minus X X minus 1 for K X minus 1
was that going it's increasing and I've
got a y-intercept of negative 1 right so
you can see I'm gonna be down here going
up yes
see what I've done again down in this
region only am i equal to this right so
this has this equation this has this
equation and you can probably start to
see what's going on now you can match
your equations look like this one's
gonna be this is minus 1 minus X minus X
minus 1 okay and lastly over here if I
rearrange this this is easy to see this
is just X plus 1 right okay so isn't
that pretty
ok so what have I done I've looked at
the four cases I've got four different
lines in four different regions and
that's it that's all there is to it